three electric vehicles are becoming a
lot more popular you've probably noticed
them on the road yeah if you've had a
little sticker shock from gasoline
prices lately maybe you're thinking
about trading in the old car getting one
of these you want to check them out
first and the energy now hosting an
electric vehicle showcase and we sent
reporter victoria salha there to join us
and show us these fancy electric cars
and there are some cool options out
there oh look at you she's ready to hit
the road
i'm riley ready heather and john i'm
sitting behind the wheel of the first
fully electric vehicle made by
volkswagen this is a very smooth vehicle
i'm gonna go ahead and take this baby
for a test drive but joining me now is
also adam grant with nv energy adam tell
us a little bit about this vehicle
so yeah as you said this is the first
all-electric vehicle from volkswagen i
want to thank the folks at findlay who
let us use this car this morning
the technology has come so far in
electric vehicles in the past couple
years the costs are down the amount of
money you spend to charge the vehicle
is down as compared to what you would
pit spend for a gasoline car
and the varieties of what a customer can
purchase now are
so
there's so much variety that
just a lot of options and the event
tomorrow um what can our folks expect so
yeah so we are showcasing all the
electric vehicles tomorrow at bruce
trent park out near the rampart casino
we're going to have a whole bunch of
variety of vehicles
tesla
hyundai volkswagen volvo
even the ford mustang maki we'll have
one out there so the all customers come
out see them get in them
really see the opportunities they have
because electric vehicles have come a
long way and we want to showcase the
great things you can do for the
environment by going electric with your
cars
and we were talking about the cost
itself if you have a charging port you
said it's under 30 bucks a week
it's actually it's about
if you charge overnight at your home it
could be about 30 dollars a month to
charge your car and when you compare
that to where gas prices are now
it's a great savings you could make by
going electric all right all righty i'm
gonna put this baby in a park um you can
see that as you as i was driving it was
very quiet if you're someone like me
that likes to escape and tune out the
world while driving this is the perfect
car for you initially you know the
prices might scary but as adam said it
could be very very cost efficient with
the charging prices given that our
gas prices are going up and down i'm
going to go ahead and enjoy this car a
little more john and heather i'm going
to send it back to you guys in the
studio it is certainly a trend victoria
around town and a lot of my friends have
gone and taken the plunge into getting
electric cars it's uh victoria wouldn't
be the only one i know it looks we'll
just drive it back here we'll take turns
running around in it
thanks victoria appreciate that